right these aren't your granddaddy's
toys james zahn is the senior insider at
the toy insider he joins us with some
samples of what's new in the world of
toys james thanks for being here hey
thanks for having me and of course
summer it we've got the summer heat
right now here in las vegas and we want
to get the family out there get people
moving so let's start it off with can
jam this is a product this is actually
made in the united states uh this comes
with a frisbee style disc here a flying
disc can jam disc you're going to get
points for shooting it in the can or
getting it through the slot so you can
give it a shot and give it either one
yeah i think like cornhole or horseshoes
but this is a new spin on it you can do
it in the yard take the beach whatever
you want to do if you get in that little
yeah you put some points on it oh
and we've got it off the table but hey
that's what it's all about that thing
comes in an awesome carrying bag so you
can take it wherever you're going okay
now
water guns blasters that type of stuff
you do but water's a little tight right
now so how about foam you can do
the foam later here which you take a
little bit of this foam solution put it
in there just a little bit of water
load it up we're not going to shoot boom
all over the studio today and i can't
say how disappointed i am that this was
nixed because originally your plan was
to shoot yes but uh you know any things
didn't work out but we've got a budget
here we can channel each other
so these are really involved these are
really great though and uh you can get
these in a single pack or a two pack
you pump it up pull it to blast it what
is the phone
is it what is it it's just a proprietary
foam solution non-toxic just kind of
just sting your eyes or nothing like
that none of that is happening how fun
that's awesome i love these waddle hip
hoppers these are from fly bar um these
are inflatable jousting oh my goodness
horses so you're basically bringing
renaissance fair to your backyard
250 pound weight capacity on each one of
those so a lot of adults can get
involved
yeah yeah and then you get your jousting
sticks and everything tons of fun those
are like 45 bucks this one though uh
you're only going to find it walmart
okay super hot item in spring going into
summer i grew up with four brothers let
me tell you if we had these it would
have turned into an all-out brawl by the
end oh started nice and they do they
actually have uh some separate ones you
can get like unicorns and dragons extend
your adventure in the backyard fun
that's awesome little tikes this is the
dirt dagger garbage scoot here this is
great for toddlers there's storage under
the seat the horn honks on there you can
steer it around
you can throw trash in this bin here
slide it up oh very good garbage yeah
and then empty it out the back so you're
teaching kids about garbage recycling
all of that stuff
for some reason kids love to see the
garden they keep coming all my kids just
loved running out to see them when they
were little and then how about bubbles
everybody loves bubbles so from sunny
days entertainment we've got the
super jet bubble blaster here and you
load this thing up this is only like 15
bucks and you can get this at all the
major retailers
and it's a ton of bubbles it comes with
a little thing a solution and you're
good to go how long will this go with
one little um it's going to go for a few
minutes then you just refill it that's
so fun that really is i don't know i
don't know that there's an age where you
get tired of bubbles no everybody loves
bubbles and we're in vegas people love
both this is fantastic so many cool
things going on right and what i love
about these is they're not necessarily
high tech no not at all yeah fairly low
tech new spins glasses
and we're just we're just having a
bubble party right yep all right thank
you boys we'll be back after this
[Music]